Poop
Most of us will not think about where they will go after washing.
But if I tell you what is very convenient
May be going back to your house
In case you didn't notice it?
Unfamiliar for those
Once your food has been chewed and swallowed, it is chemically broken down,
After the useful nutrients are absorbed by your body,
The rest is elegantly discarded as waste
These wastes
Mix with a mixture of urine, rain, shower, wash basin
And other family waters to the local
Sewer system, surprisingly
Mainly contains water and relative
Small stool, like a big old
Bowl of soup with very few vegetables
Passing a few miles
After the potential tube, the soup reaches
Sewage treatment plant, and preliminary screening
Separated from degreasing
Things like sand, gravel and pebbles.
More importantly, this is a mobile phone that says you are not careful.
Was caught with a condom? And other things that you think are thrown into the toilet is a good idea.
By the way, this is not a good idea.
For every piece of rubbish or item you throw the toilet down
The more likely it is blocked in the system, it will be removed
And have to use the hand..
No one wants this.
Pebbles and grit, on the other hand, are
Drying, cleaning, recycling like building
May help create
Your ivory throne.
Then the remaining stool mixture is allowed to stand
In a huge water river.
And benefit from the fundamental nature of both sides
Oils and greases such as non-polar substances,
Not mixed with water,
It is easier to skim them.
However, you really shouldn’t
It has nothing to lose because it may block the pipeline
And overwhelming complex systems.
Now there is some silt and the rest.
A stinky liquid that looks like chocolate milk.
Well, chocolate milk!
This is how it tastes like millions of bacteria
This is a set of loose and feasting
mixture. They are really eating pathogens
Liquid
Most of these bacteria are aerobic,
This means they need oxygen to work,
Just like humans,
So the river is full of oxygen.
Then the water is sterilized and
Put it back in the environment.
On the other hand, excess sludge,
Mainly containing solid waste,
After final processing with another group
Bacteria. These bacteria produce
Various by-products, including methane
Gas, which is used again for power
Sewage treatment plant.
So your poop increases the power of the plants, they
Handle your poop.
After eating everything, the bacteria died
And build some that are called biosolids.
After all said that,
The rest, nutrient-rich feces and biosolids
Can be used to make compost
Rich in dry land, or used as fertilizer,
This ultimately helps to increase vegetation.
Vegetation, this vegetation uses its way
Came to your home and eventually
To your mouth.
Start the cycle of feces again,
Come back from the beginning
This episode of ASAP Science is supported by squarespace.com
If you have a story to say, whether it's about starting a new business or sharing photos from our recent adventures, Squarespace gives you a platform to post these stories online.
Modern templates, mobile responsive design, simple drag and drop tools, and 24-hour support
You can create a professional website in just a few minutes.
For a free trial and a 10% discount on a new account purchase, at: squarespace.com and use the code, Asap8
Thanks again to squarespace for supporting Asap Science